hi my name is Maddie
I'm a full-time numpy developer how many
people here use numpy very good that's
about what I expected how many people
have a github login or github username
and use github okay how many people have
registered an issue on github in an open
source package an issue that's pretty
good is about a third and how many
people have done a pull request
we got about how about the same number
that's that's good and how many people
have put an issue into numpy pythons I
PI the scientific stack nobody oh one
good alright so I'm here to do three
things this evening and something like
twenty minutes I hope one is to
entertain you a bit one is to convince
you that open source is something that
you can do that it's not that scary that
it's and it's it's something you could
become passionate about and the third is
to a little bit talk about where we're
going with numpy and what we hope the
future will bring for numpy so I'm going
to talk about my personal story how I
got involved in open source here we go
my first steps with open so I moved
Israel in 1982 and I started a kibbutz
down south kibbutz Lotan anyone ever
heard of it
it's in the Arve yeah so good it was a
great place I spent about 10 years there
and then in 1993 I started doing a PhD
at the Technion and I took over a
laboratory in the Technion that was I
was in agriculture engineering coming
out of the kibbutz you know we worship
where should I go about agricultural
engineering and I took over a laborat
with actual controllers with with
hardware and we had to do it in C code
and I was teaching undergrads how to use
C and how do interface with this with
easy with this equipment and we had a
net where network that was supported by
the Technion but it didn't have internet
access and so the internet was just
getting out in 1994 is becoming really
popular so I took the server and I
converted it into Slackware that was my
first steps with open-source I
downloaded stuff from the nascent
internet and started compiling it and I
also did my doctorate in in MATLAB and I
created something that called it an
adaptive sorting toolbox and I thought
it was really cool and that other people
should be able to use it and so mat
people use MATLAB how many people still
use MATLAB good it's a great program
it's okay it's alright don't be ashamed
it's alright you should move to Python
but there are things that Python does
that MATLAB can't there PI that MATLAB
does it Python can't do and so keep
using it's a great program I in return
for giving MATLAB my adaptive sorting
toolbox oh well what happened was I
tried to upload it to their what's their
sharing platform called they have the
sum sum MATLAB central very good someone
someone still remembers what it's called
they have this sharing site where you
can download other people's MATLAB
toolboxes I thought I'd load it upload
it to there I asked him how I upload it
they said well hang on a minute that's a
pretty interesting toolbox you've got
there sell it to us I said ok I want a
lifetime license for MATLAB and so I
have a lifetime license for MATLAB for
anybody who wants to use it is more than
welcome and those were my first steps
with open-source ok not very successful
those first steps and then I plunged
into a whole different world the world
of C++ real men you know we're doing C++
we're not even like women don't even
like get close right this was this was
in the ages of when when when men were
men visual studio doing image processing
I wrote tests to hold test harnesses in
in C++ and we even wrote CGI scripts
executables that ran on the server in C
compiled them loaded him up to the
server ran him under Apache it was a
different world but then I saw the light
I discovered Python in about
in 3 or 2006 and started writing my
tests in Python that was the first thing
I did and I discovered that you really
don't have to write everything alone you
know you can use other people's stuff
we're using numpy and OpenCV to work
with 2d matrices and my get my github I
joined in 2011 and my first
contributions were touring Arduino
Ethernet shield I had an issue there
with it with the way the ethernet was
working and tried to fix it for him and
then I found myself not really fully
employed I had a little free time in the
evening when I could play around with
stuff and I was looking for a hard
problem and I found pi PI anybody know
what pi PI is py py
all right good you use it in production
nah played with it good all right so I
found pi PI and I found this demo that
they did found out this pi PI status
blog and and what they did was they
started PI PI's an alternative Python
implementation ok PI C Python is written
in C pi PI is written in python has a
JIT it has a just-in-time compiler so
you run your code in it and it thinks
about your code and about the through
the thousandth time that you've run that
code through the loop
it says AHA that's a hot loop I'm gonna
compile that down to assembler turns it
into assembler and from then on it's
it's running in assembler and not in
Python so they had this really cool demo
they did where they got Sobel working
can you see there it's pretty small ctrl
shift plus where PI C Python was doing
this Sobel in in about a tenth of a
frame a second and pipe I was running in
in 50 frames per second they were um
taking a video from a from a webcam and
doing a soul Bowl Sobel transformation I
mean anything to anybody so ball filter
finding the outlines ok good there's
some image processing people here you
are the same people who are contributing
open-source you guys like just like
raising your hands don't you
okay so they connected a webcam to the
to this and they were doing the Sobel
transformation in real time on pi PI I
thought that was really cool and and
then they had a call to action they said
let's put numpy into pi pi so that
became my Sudoku who does Sudoku here
what do you guys do in the evening when
you're like bored fortnight no I don't
know you know so like I used to do
Sudoku when I'd like have a couple of
hours spare I'd spend some time just on
the looking at Sudoku and so I decided
to do to try and do this instead and so
I really got involved in pushing commits
to this repository of pi PI and and
helping write tests and we did
test-driven development and pushing dumb
pi into pi pi and by November of 2011 I
was hooked
here is my open this is MA do you guys
know open hub open hub is a great site
if you're looking for quality of open
source you're trying to figure out how
good opens open source packages go to
open hub it look about it and you can
also look up people that's me
and you can see my commit history on in
all the packages I've contributed to
I've done over 3,000 commits in about
seven years and you can see when I've
been active when I've been on vacation
doing some other so I really got hooked
into this whole open source thing now
let's get back to the story and moving
on so one thing led to another I became
very involved in the open source
community I started giving courses for
scientific Python helping people move
from MATLAB to Python where it was
appropriate helped set up in large
organizations help them set up tracking
of open source packages where they're
using them because they're people who
actually produce a product that they're
selling to someone they the people want
to know what packages are inside those
products we needed license policies
about what licenses were permitted and
not permitted and I started giving talks
about opens
I gave a talk at PyCon Israel in 2016
about pie-pie and in Pike on Israel 2017
about cff I see types and psyphon see
types you know about right cff I anybody
know about it's a way to wrap see called
the same people use pipeline you know
everything
it's a way to wrap see in Python it's
and it's also very fast and siphon I
hope people know about if not you should
learn about it and then in november the
berkeley institute for data science
opened up a contract for to hire two to
three people to work full-time on numpy
so since april I've been working at the
University of California in Berkeley I'm
working half there and half at home
because I have a family I'd like to be
with my family I like them still and
I've been working on numpy so that's how
I got involved I kind of got dragged in
not dragged in but I kind of like got
sucked in in 2011 or so 2012 and so over
the past five or six years I've been
boosting up my open source contributions
become my passion and finally found
myself actually working on it and
getting a salary for it um so what I do
in the summer when I was at numpy
working on at the University of
California in Berkeley I was there for
three months and I was working on numpy
we now have a road map I'm happy to talk
about we have what we call numpy
enhancement proposals ways we're gonna
move numpy forward i'm gave a couple of
talks at Syfy in Austin Texas and next
week I'm going off to Italy to give a
talk at Euro Syfy what I can say about
numpy is that oh so how is it how is all
this work how am i doing one time okay
yeah okay so how is it being an
open-source contributor okay first thing
you've got to know gotta have thick skin
okay because your work is out there on
the internet you have to be you can't be
ashamed to make very public mistakes if
you have like problems with ego and
stuff like that
then you're gonna have problems with
open source I myself put a bug into
numpy release 114 for in June and then
we had to make a 114 5 because of that
bug it was a really small bug but it was
worth in a new release and a lot of my
commits if you go into PI pi and you
look at their commit history all the
commit logs you'll see a lot of typos
whoops didn't work back out this one and
that's all up there on the internet I
mean if someone ever wants to employ me
and they want to look at my commit
history they'll see all those commits
they'll see some really good commits to
but they'll see all the ones that either
got rejected or that we're pretty stupid
in the first place and you need a lot of
patience open-source moves very slowly
it's based on volunteers you can put in
an issue like about a quarter or a third
of you have done and nothing will happen
for a couple weeks and then maybe
someone will look at it or you can you
can write a pull request you can you
know spend a week weekend writing your
your pull request nothing will happen to
it you'll ask them what's going on and
they'll say yeah we don't really have
time to deal with this right now
so you need a lot of patience to work on
open source so I can talk a little about
the roadmap of numpy I can talk a little
bit about pipe I what we did over the
summer is we tried to define what we
want numpy to be and what we what we
view as the scope of numpy and what
review is going to be outside of the
scope of numpy numpy as most of you know
is an in-memory and dimensional
homogeneously type arrays on the CPU
okay so we view our mandate as people
use numpy and tensorflow
in Ind ask anybody used to ask yeah okay
good in in lots of other situations but
that's actually not numpy okay desk is a
numpy what we call a duck array it looks
like a what we call a module with a
single type array on a CPU but it's
distributed across a number of computers
in tensorflow
that single pointer is up on the
GPU it's not on the CPU okay there's
another package called coupe I that also
does this numpy isn't gonna do that okay
but what we are gonna do is we're gonna
support all those other users of numpy
and we're gonna give them a higher level
API so that they can write their stuff
we'll write our stuff and the world will
still be happy and we'll have one
interface you'll still do say import
tensorflow from tensorflow import ndra
you'll still get an indie array that you
can do means some you can do all the
other things linear algebra on it it'll
still work the same if you use numb PI's
in memory CPU array or if you use tensor
flows see a GPU array or if you use
desks distributed array that's our hope
that's one of the big things working on
the other things were that we're trying
to work on in our roadmap is the D types
people know what D types are right so
you this instant this in-memory
homogeneously typed array every piece in
that array has a D type pets it's either
an int 32 or an in 64 and into a tour or
maybe it's a you can actually define a
struct if you want to get really
complicated so we want to make that
whole system a lot easier to use a lot
easier to work with we wanted so that
people can actually inherit from those d
types and make their own if they're
going to be categorical things like pant
what pandas does these days or they can
be have units attached to those d types
so if you have an in 32 it might also be
a foot or a meter or a mile that's
pretty much what we're we wanted to go
with numpy and pi pi for those of you
who don't know about it I had a slide up
here but pi PI is another implementation
of Python so in Python you when you when
you probably download it from anaconda
that's what most people do you get an
interpreter that's written in C pi PI
you get it and you can download an
interpreter that's actually written in
Python translated into C
and as I said it has a JIT with it and a
garbage collector that's a different lot
faster garbage collector so if you want
to write native Python code and have it
run very fast you should do it in pi PI
I think I'll stop here did I own your
time yeah okay
did I convince you that you should try
and do some open source maybe okay and I
hope I've given you some information
about where numpy is gonna go and I'm
gonna be here like we're gonna take a
break soon right no yeah but so people
are yeah so I'm happy to entertain
questions now in the future and Madi
PICUs my github name is ma ttip
an RLC and one of the things that I view
as my job as a full-time numpy developer
is to encourage people to get into this
world to get involved make your first
pull request make your first issue now
file some issues make some pull requests
and get involved in the community so
it's no longer world of just of old
white men you know using C++ and so
let's get everybody doing open source
questions don't be scared
yeah repeat the question the the mkl
distribution of numpy okay how do we
relate to it as open-source developers
this is a commercial venture that's kind
of making things work faster on their
chips we're very happy that people are
using numpy and we view it as our
mission that in people use matplotlib
yeah people use Boca and and the other
plotly and all those others that world
is starting to fragment that world is
starting to like there's all these other
implementations of ways to do plotting
in the Python world that kind of scares
us okay and then in the numpy community
we don't want that to happen to numpy we
don't want there to be a fracturing of
the API of the high-level API I want
people to be able to import something
whether it be Intel MKL numpy or desk or
whatever and be able to use those api's
consistently so we have a good
relationship it's kind of annoying when
we get bugs that are due to their
compilers but we work it out pretty
quickly and we help them work through
their issues and you know it's all it's
all good so they should they should be
healthy and and give us lots of money
and more questions yeah okay so the
question is this whole berkeley
institute of data science bids place
what's going on there what's the story
there so there's a couple of
philanthropic organizations in the world
the Moore Foundation and the I just
blanked out on the other one it'll come
to me
that have given money to promote
reproducible science they view it they
view science as something that should be
belong to everyone and at the end of the
day we're paying for it right we're the
ones supporting our taxes are going to
supporting these scientists doing all
this academic research
or at least our tuition or our taxes are
going to it and so all that science
should be open should be reproducible so
the these foundations have given money
to to establish three institutes across
the United States ones in Berkeley ones
in University of Washington in Seattle
and ones in New York they're called
institutes of data science they all have
their own little names and their niche
things that are going on there
these sloan Foundation that's the other
one this sloan Foundation the Moore
Foundation gave a grant to numpy through
the Berkeley Institute for data science
to hire a couple of people me being one
of them
Tyler Reddy is another one there's two
of us to work on numpy full-time so the
two of us are working there our managers
are actually the numpy community there's
a steering council of about 20 people
who are volunteers who are
representatives of the numpy community
people who are active in committing and
reviewing pull requests and we have
someone at bids who's our like our
day-to-day manager making sure we get
salaries and they would get paid but we
viewer that the community is actually
driving our our agenda and what we're
doing I don't know if I answered your
question but I kind of described the
situation more questions yeah can I
compare the experiences of working in
different places I've worked in a
start-up where we were two people and I
worked in a very large software company
in the north of the country and I'm now
working on open-source in basically in
an academic situation I have to say that
it's a lot slower and demands a lot more
patience than either of the other two
options if you're any if you're in a
large company
there's always room to like push your
agenda forward and you can kind of
create this you can carve out your own
little your own little your own little
enterprise sometimes your own little
atmosphere if you're to start up of
course things are moving fast and you're
breaking them all the time we can't
break numpy right people get we'll get
rare Ino
if we do a release that breaks numpy so
we have to be very careful with with
every commit we do we have to be most
large software mouths large open source
software projects don't have no idea who
their end users are until they piss them
off right then we hear who's actually
using the software until then we have no
idea how many you know there's millions
downloads a month we don't know where
that stuff is going or who's doing what
with it and what corners they're going
to actually discover that we we changed
something we changed the printing in
between 113 and 114 change the way that
the when you print an array the way it's
displayed on the screen we got lots of
issues about it okay people are very
very upset that now it shows five five
places after the after the period where
rather than seven okay so those are the
kinds of things you have to deal with
and you have to be careful not to break
so you have to move very slowly and also
working with volunteers
it means like I described before it
means that things take a long time you
need a lot of patience yes more yes yeah
so we have a we have a test suite that
has about 5,000 tests in it I think and
that's before that's just within the
numpy test suite itself so we're we use
Jenkins circle CI and app there to test
on Linux windows and we're just starting
now to test on arm v8 and then before we
do a release we ask we do a pre release
and we ask downstream users like sigh hi
Astro PI people we have good
communication with please try it out
they run their test suite on it and tell
us if we broken something so it's all
test-driven development and hopefully
what we try to ensure is that every time
someone does a pull request that pull
request has coverage within the test
suite we run G coverage to make sure
that we're running the lines of code
that we think we're running and pull
request should always have tests with
them
[Music]
[Applause]